hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts our keynote presentation
targeting molecular chaperones in cancer
lessons learned from each SP 90
presented by dr. Len necker's senior
investigator at the National Cancer
Institute Center for cancer research I'm
Suzy doll des of lab routes and I'll be
your moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located at the lower left of your
presentation window and type those
questions into the box that appear on
the screen dr. nekaris will be following
up with your questions via email and
answering them in order also please
notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge that window just click on that
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing the presentation click on the
support button or the Q&A button and let
us know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and best
offers continuing education credits
please click on the button in the bottom
left hand corner and follow the process
to obtain your credits without further
ado please join me in welcoming dr. Len
necker's I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome dr.
necker's
today I'm going to talk to you about our
experience targeting molecular
chaperones in cancer and lessons we've
learned from hsp90 in normal cells hsp90
is involved in a proto stasis network
that maintains the viability of cells in
cancer cells this includes maintenance
of a number of mutated and or activated
unka proteins including some kindnesses
that are cancer associated transcription
factors etc the offend the importance of
hsp90 differs and dependence on hsp90
differs between normal cells and cancer
cells that i want to give you an example
of how we can interpret that so this is
an experiment using yeast grown at
optimal temperature with wild-type hsp90
and from this graph you can see that the
viability of these yeast are not
affected until the expression level of
hsp90 is reduced by as much as 90% so
there's a huge excess of hsp90 under
optimal growth conditions in these
organisms now if we make a temperature
sensitive mutation to hsp90
as shown in the red box at optimal
growth conditions there's still no
effect on growth comparing wild-type
growth to growth of the w 585 t mutant
but if you now put the yeast under
suboptimal temperature in this case 16
degrees you can see that the mutant is
unable to support growth while the
wild-type and two other mutants are
completely able to support
showing that while this particular
mutation functions perfectly at optimal
temperature it's unable to support yeast
growth at suboptimal
temperature another way of looking at
this is looking at expression strength
of hsp90 comparing that of wild-type to
yeast mutants in particular we're
focusing on the yeast mutant W 585 T
that's in the red box and you can see as
you decrease the expression of this
mutant viability of the yeast is shown
by conversion from the yellow color to
the blue color is compromised at the
same time a similar reduction in
expression of wild-type hsp90 has no
effect so although these yeast are being
run under optimal conditions reduced
expression of the mutant has
consequences for viability in other
words the yeast become more dependent on
high levels of expression of this mutant
so diagrammatically if you now look at
normal cells they can tolerate a large
reduction in the levels of hsp90 without
any obvious effects on Fitness whereas
if you stress these cells they become
much more dependent on high expression
of hsp90 and if you exchange stress for
a cancer our working hypothesis over the
years has been the cancer cells have a
greater dependence on hsp90 relative to
normal cells so that a significant
portion of this chaperone can be
pharmacologically inhibited in normal
cells without any obvious effects but
similar inhibition in kin
two cells is likely to be cytotoxic in
fact hsp90 is known to modulate a cell's
response to many different kinds of
noxious environments that are frequently
characteristic of the cancer environment
and lifestyle
these include nutrients stress
proteotoxic stress hypoxia and genetic
instability frequent characteristics of
many cancers hsp90 clients those
proteins that are chaperoned by hsp90
are integral in allowing cells to
respond to these insults a number of
studies have shown and one is provided
here that amplification and high level
expression of hsp90 is correlated with
aggressive phenotypes of different kinds
of cancers including lung cancer and in
this case her2 negative breast cancer so
what these data showed in this paper
published in 2012 is that looking at
survival as a function of hsp90
expression in patients with triple
negative breast cancer shows that
patients whose tumors have upregulated
hsp90 expression show significantly
poorer overall survival compared to
patients whose tumors have less hsp90
expression and again this has been
repeated over the years for many kinds
of cancers so what does inhibiting hsp90
do from what I've shown you so far
and based on yeast models the likelihood
is that or the expectation
that inhibiting hsp90 compromises the
robustness of a cancer cell and some
preliminary evidence that this is the
case was shown in a paper that we
published now a number of years ago
using hsp90 inhibitors in this case the
first hsp90 inhibitors in clinical trial
17a AG as a radio sensitizing agent so
there are three cervical cancer cell
lines here and what we're showing is
that in each case inclusion of a small
amount of hsp90 inhibitor is able to
promote radio sensitization in vitro of
these cells and this radio sensitization
is in fact dose dependent and time
dependent so how does hsp90 function
this is understanding this is critical
to understanding how pharmacologic hsp90
inhibitors work ATP binding and ATP
hydrolysis are essential for the
function of hsp90 in vitro and in vivo
looking at the crystal structure of
hsp90 this is just focusing in on the N
domain of the protein we can see there's
an ATP binding pocket and this ATP
binding pocket turns out to be the
binding site of two of the original
natural product hsp90 inhibitors that
were identified galdana myosin and
reducer call so when hsp90 which is a
dimer exists in the absence of
nucleotide it's considered to be in
what's called an open conformation where
the N domains are under mirai's as shown
here in the presence of ATP and the N
domains closed a number of
conformational changes occur
and ATP binding and hydrolysis is
important for driving this
conformational cycle in the presence of
hsp90 inhibitors ATP can't find hsp90
remains in an open conformation and the
consequences of this for client proteins
is that they're ubiquitinated by III
proteins associating with these
chaperones and ultimately degraded by
the proteasome we've identified two such
III ubiquitin ligases that associate
with both hsp90 and hsp70
one is chip and the other is colin v
development of hsp90 inhibitors has gone
on since the early 90s and we're showing
here the increased number of hsp90
inhibitors all binding to the ATP pocket
that have entered clinical trial since
the late 1990s
unfortunately inhibitors that are
currently in clinical trial are only
represented by a few by a few can't
candidates as shown on this slide
including SN x v 4 2 2 81 3 3 8 7x
alixus 8 8 8 pu h 71 tas 1 1 6 and a new
compound which I'll talk about towards
the end of the talk pen 8 6 6 no hsp90
inhibitor has yet been approved by the
FDA
although active trials of hsp90
inhibitors of these agents currently in
clinical trial is shown here and you can
see that many of these studies involve
combined
p90 inhibitors with other agents some
anecdote anecdotal studies clearly show
that hsp90 inhibitors are effective
clinically in certain kinds of cancers
this is a relatively early study using
17 AG and her2 positive breast cancer
patients who stopped responding to the
antibody Herceptin when 17 AG was
included along with Herceptin there was
a significant response rate of 26% and
an overall clinical benefit rate of 63%
in these patients whose cancers were
otherwise no longer responding to
treatment similarly in a phase 2 study
of non-small cell lung cancer and other
hsp90 inhibitor used as monotherapy
showed significant responses in alcove
non small cell lung cancer and in k
wrasse mutant small cell lung cancer
this is an example of a patient's tumor
shown at baseline on the left hand side
in the red circles and arrows and after
three weeks of ganna tested treatment B
and Gannett tested is the hsp90
inhibitors used in this case and it
should be noted that this patient
previously progressed on chemotherapy
received the alkene hibbett of
crizotinib for one year and then
progressed on that and then and only
then enrolled in this Gannet SP of mono
therapy trial and showed clear responses
Gannet SP of activity has also been seen
in mutant b-raf non small cell lung
cancer again after the patient
progressed on various forms of
chemotherapy single agent responds to
hsp90 inhibitors clearly evident in the
images below lastly this slide
represents a targeted approach beyond
Alec and again this is triple negative
breast cancer which I previously showed
you a few slides ago is is aggressively
related to high expression of hsp90 and
here again single agent treatment of a
patient with Gannett SP who has stopped
responding and progressed on various
forms of chemotherapy show clear
responses so these data would suggest
that hsp90 inhibition is in fact able to
compromise the fitness of cancer cells
and should show reproducible and robust
clinical activity however since no drug
showed sufficient activity so far to be
approved by the FDA we and others have
looked into this question further and
have noticed that another consequence of
hsp90 inhibition is to induce what is
known as the heat shock response by
potentiating activity of the master
transcriptional regulator of the heat
shock response heat shock factor one or
hsf one the heat shock response
in a way is poorly named because it's
initiated by many types of proteotoxic
stress including elevated temperature
oxidative stress exposure to heavy
metals and bacterial or viral infection
but upon activation of the heat shock
response which is mediated by hsf one
one sees an upregulation of proteins
involved in produce
including the heat shock proteins hsp70
HSB 27 and hsp90 itself and if hsp90
inhibitors activate or potentiate hsf 1
this becomes a potential problem in
cancer treatment this is a Western blot
which I want to show you as an example
in Irby 2 overexpressing breast cancer
cells so here we're using the
prototypical hsp90 inhibitors gilt atom
Ison on where do we're using a dose
response to look at loss of verb be to
protein due to degradation in the
proteome and looking to see when we see
induction of hsp70 and as you can see as
soon as there's an effect on the client
herb b2 there is an upregulation of
hsp70 protein expression another hsp90
dependent client phospho or activated
akt is similarly affected at an
equivalent dose that induces hsp70
importantly as shown in the bottom two
panels HSC 70 the constitutive isoform
of hsp70 is unaffected by hsp90
inhibitors treatment so only the stress
inducible form hsp70 is affected and
this is consistent with dependence on
hsf one expression in fact looking at
levels of hsp70 mRNA or protein has been
used as a pharmacodynamic marker in
patients on hsp90 inhibitors clinical
trials so you can see from this figure
that there is a dose and time dependent
increase in hsp70 in patient blood
after treatment and it depends on how
many cycles of treatment the more cycles
of treatment the higher the induction of
hsp70 is and this has actually been used
as a biomarker in clinical trials to
show that we're hitting the target but
in retrospect this appears to be an
indication that we may be obviating the
effect of the anti-cancer activity of
hsp90 inhibitors by promoting this
tissue protective response to further
complicate matters the Lindquist lab
published a study a number of years ago
showing that in addition to inducing a
cytoprotective heat shock response in
all cells including cancer as well as
normal hsf one drives a cancer specific
set of genes that promote the growth and
viability of cancer cells so this is an
additional reason why one would not want
to upregulate or activate hsf one in
fact if one looks at hsp70 expression in
tumor one sees that like hsp90 it
correlates with poor survival so this is
an a study of survival in breast cancer
where the HS of one status of the
patient's tumor has been evaluated and
there's a highly statistically
significant correlative effect of Aegeus
of one expression shown by the red line
and poorer survival compared to low or
no ages of one expression in tumors
shown by the black line
agreeing with this observation if one
looks at TCGA data that has recently
appeared and is available yeah one sees
that hsf one is overexpressed
significantly in a wide variety of
cancers comparing its over expression to
mix which is frequently over expressed
in cancer as you can see that in many of
the various cancers shown here and
they're delineated on the x-axis HS f1
expression over expression is greater
and more pronounced across this range of
cancers than is seem ik so it's becoming
very apparent that cancer cells depend
on HS f 1 for growth viability and
survival and that a targeted agent that
results in increasing the activity of HS
f1 is is not going to promote an
anti-cancer response we wondered what
the mechanism behind hsp90 effects on HS
f 1 is because understanding the
mechanism may allow us to intercede and
and block the effects of hsp90 so the
current model that's been in the
literature for many years is that hsp90
binds to monomers of h s f1 in
unstressed cells and in the presence of
misfolded proteins caused by proteotoxic
stress such as heat shock hsp90 comes
off of ages of 1 to deal with the
misfolded proteins and allows HS f1 to
trimer eyes which it must do to become
an active transcription factor
so how do i chess p90 inhibitors affect
the hs8 HSR or heat shock response based
on this model the concept was that hsp90
inhibitors by preventing ATP from
binding to hsp90 caused dissociation of
hsp90 from monomeric HS f1 and similarly
to heat shock allow HS f1 to trimer eyes
and become an active transcription
factor so the dogma in the literature is
that hsp90 functions as a repressor of
HS f1 activation it functions as a
sensor of proteotoxic stress and release
of HS f one from hsp90 is a key event if
not the key event in induction of the
heat shock response so we asked
ourselves does this model make sense and
in fact we came to the conclusion that
it does not first of all it's extremely
difficult to visualize the interaction
of endogenous hsp90 and HS f1 in cells
without chemical cross-linking and a
recent study in fact in vitro showed
that the constitutive isoform of hsp90
actually promotes temperature dependent
try memorization of HS f1 inconsistent
with the current model so we decided to
examine more closely if we could detect
a stable interaction of hsp90 with HS f
1 and to do that we use two sets of
mutants the first set of mutants keeps
hsp90 in an open conformation by
preventing ATP binding the second set of
mutants shown on the right keeps hsp90
in a closed conformation by allowing ATP
binding
preventing ATP hydrolysis we've made
both sets of mutations in hsp90 alpha
the stress inducible form of hsp90 and
beta the constitutively expressed form
of hsp90 and what we found as many
others have found is that wild-type
hsp90 is not able to be detected
associating with hsf one without
cross-linking however the closed mutant
d 47 a of hsp90 alpha readily associates
with hsf one yeah in immuno
precipitation assays the close mutant of
the beta isoform also associates but not
as strongly as stress inducible hsp90
alpha so what this is telling us is that
the ATP bound hsp90 can associate and
it's association is readily detectable
with hsp90 but in human hsp90 the ATP
dependent closed conformation is very
transient and is only infrequently
accessed by the chaperone even in the
presence of ATP we next look to see the
what whether the impact of hsp90
inhibitors on this interaction was
similar to other induces of the heat
shock response including heat rock
itself as well as produce some
inhibition so what we found is three
different hsp90 inhibitors that have
been in clinical trial all dissociate
hsf one from this closed hsp90 alpha
mutant as shown on the left however
neither the produce um inhibitor mg 132
nor heat rock itself dissociates
d is the interaction of clothes hsp90
with HS f 1 making the point that HS f 1
dissociation from hsp90 is clearly not a
prerequisite for induction of the HS r
so what hsp90 inhibitors are doing is
unique so how can we explain what hsp90
inhibitors are doing to potentiate the
heat shock response a clue came from
this experiment where we're looking at
hsp70 reporter activity and cells
treated either with 17 AG alone he choc
alone or the combination there and then
they're allowed to recover for four
hours at normal temperature and you can
see that 17 AG alone has a minimal
effect on hsp70 driven reporter activity
heat shock has an effect as expected but
the combination of 17 AG in heat Chuck
has a synergistic effect that is much
higher than one would expect from just
an additive response so this led us to
ask the question perhaps hsp90 and
particularly hsp90 alpha may be working
to shut off the heat shock response as a
feedback mechanism and that by
dissociating hsp90 alpha from HS f1
bound to HS f1 elements in promoters
this results in potentiation of
transcriptional activity and
prolongation of the heat shock response
to examine this hypothesis we did in HS
f1 chromatin immunoprecipitation a sec
shown here and we looked at
hsf one binding to both the hsp70
promoter as well as the hsp90 promoter
two genes that are regulated by HS f1
and we either expose cells to heat shock
alone for 30 minutes or first pretreated
with the hsp90 inhibitors 17 AG for two
hours followed by 30 minutes of heat
shock and then allowed recovery from
anywhere from five minutes to six hours
and monitored by chip association of HS
f1 with DNA what you can see in the
absence of 17 hg if you look at both the
hsp70 promoters shown in blue and the
hsp90 promoter and read that and of
course represents no heat shock and
that's set to one so all these values
are in relation to no heat shock after
five minutes of recovery from heat shock
you see a big increase in HS f1 bound to
both hsp70 in particular but also hsp90
promoter regions but this effect is lost
by two hours where HS f binding goes
below baseline and remains below
baseline for the duration of the
experiment
however if cells are pretreated with 17
AG prior to heat shock you see an
increase in HS f1 binding in the absence
of heat shock and a continuation of this
binding during the recovery for a much
longer time then in cells treated with
heat shock alone so finding above
control persists for at least 4 4 hours
if not longer and this results in
increased HS of one dependent
transcription as well as translation and
can explain the induction of hsp70
caused by hsp90
that I showed you before they send these
data we've come up with a working model
to explain what hsp90 is doing to
regulate the heat shock response we
think that hsp90 alpha in particular as
an HS of one target gene serves to
provide feedback control to the heat
shock response by binding to HS f1 and
removing it from DNA hsp90 inhibitors in
contrast by dissociating hsp90 alpha
from HS f1 prevent this from happening
block the feedback control and extend
the duration of HS f1 transcriptional
activity bound to DNA understanding this
mechanism as perhaps the true model of
what hsp90 inhibitors are doing is
allowing us to look for novel strategies
to disrupt the ability of hsp90
inhibitors to dissociate hsp90 from HS
f1 or to otherwise block h s f1
transcriptional activity for the last
part of this talk I want to describe a
novel use of hsp90 inhibitors that does
not involve its ability to degrade
client client proteins but only to
deliver cytotoxic drugs to tumour cells
and to prolong the their duration within
the tumor cell so one of the
characteristics of hsp90 inhibitors as a
class has been known for many years to
localize to tumour cells and to remain
at relatively high concentration in
tumor cells for much longer than in
normal tissues so
researchers at sense of pharmaceuticals
designed a a conjugate approach where
they attached a linker to their hsp90
inhibitor and coupled their hsp90
inhibitor to the active metabolite of
arena T can arena t can as the tow is a
topoisomerase one inhibitor whose active
metabolite SN 38 is highly cytotoxic and
causes significant toxicity to normal
tissues so the folks had sent to
hypothesize that by delivering this
toxic molecule directly to tumor cells
and maintaining it at relatively high
concentrations in tumor cells for an
extended time because of its attachment
to hsp90 might not only improve its
efficacy toward tumor inhibition or
killing but also reduce its systemic
toxicity and this has in fact proved to
be the case in collaboration with Lee
Hellman and Kristine Heskey in the
pediatric oncology branch here at NCI
we've looked at use of this conjugate in
animal models of Ewing sarcoma and
rhabdomyosarcoma to pediatric sarcomas
that are frequently treated with the
reno t kin but invariably stopped
responding after in a certain time shown
in these graphs are the responses of a
rhabdomyosarcoma line rh 32 either hsp90
inhibitors alone which is can attest but
in this case shown and the red line in
panel a 2 arena t can alone shown in the
purple line and two three different
doses of this conjugate that I've
discussed shown in the yellow
blue and dark purple lines as you can
see hsp90 inhibitors itself is
ineffective in inhibiting the growth of
our age 30 Sina graphs in mice while
arena T can although initially very
effective eventually loses activity and
the tumors return in contrast the drug
conjugate in a dose-dependent manner is
able to significantly prolong regression
of these tumors the result is even more
dramatic in a Ewing sarcoma model shown
in panel B where you can see again that
can attest boob alone the hsp90
inhibitors is ineffective arre no T can
as expected is very effective but it's
it's anti-cancer activity is transient
and again there's a dose-dependent
effect of the conjugate such that at a
doses at doses that are achievable in
humans there is essentially no
recurrence of this cancer after two
treatments this is also observed in a
Ewing sarcoma model subjected to
protracted therapy with arena t can
compared to the conjugate as you can see
even though arena t can treatment is
protracted two tumors eventually will
regrow but two treatments with the
conjugated hsp90 in reno t can act a
metabolite caused complete regression in
this tumor model and complete survival
of the mice lastly this is a Ewing
sarcoma
PDX model otherwise naive to arena t can
you can see that the arena t can respond
shown in purple lasts for a significant
amount
time but eventually two tumors become
non-responsive addition of hsp90
inhibitor together with the arena t can
but as two separate agents has no
significant benefit but again the
conjugate of hsp90 inhibitors to arena t
can shows much better activity we looked
in these tumors at markers of arena t
can activity one of which is gamma h2ax
an indicator of DNA damage caused by a
reno t can and in panels a and B you can
see that expression of gamma h2ax an
indicator of ongoing DNA damage persists
far longer in the conjugate treated
animals then in animals treated with
arena t can alone and lastly in the
bottom panel we looked at a series of
genes that are either upregulated or
downregulated in response to arena t can
and the arena t canna alone
samples are shown in orange and the
conjugates samples are shown in blue and
you can see that in both cases but
actually most obviously in those genes
that are down regulated in response to
reno t can the conjugate is
significantly more active these exciting
data have led to initiation of a first
in human clinical trial of this
conjugate term ten eight six six
sponsored by tar beta their therapeutics
opening at the NCI and other sites in
july of this year and this is now open
for enrollment with that I'll stop and
I'd like to acknowledge the
folks in my lab that participated in
these experiments other investigators in
NCI whose collaboration was essential to
our work and collaborators from Senta
pharmaceuticals
who initially supplied us with the
conjugate of hsp90 inhibitor and arena t
can thank you very much for listening